avant d'être propre moi j'étais
ingénieur j'ai bossé six ans dans
l'industrie mais là je m'appuie
fabuleuse expérience industrielle
garde dalloux âgé de 45 ans je suis déjà
deux enfants et j'exerce le métier de
prof de maths dans un lycée agricole en
bretagne
je me suis retrouvé d'embringuer dans
l'initiative actuellement incroyable qui
s'appelle les visières solidaire c'est
un collectif de deux particuliers qui
ont des imprimantes 3d depuis qu'ils ont
fabriqués solidairement gratuitement
bénévolement fabriquer et livrer des
miliaires des dispositifs de protection
qui vient d'un complément dé les deux
pays étudient des masques ffp2 que les
soignants ils n'ont pas eu peu ou pas
beaucoup voilà pour aider à leur
protection
[Musique]
pas loin de 200 personnes pourront
j'enjoins et puis on n'aura pas mérité
que 2310 hier pour un surplus pour les
soignants et les professionnels qui m'a
demandé alors je veux savoir quelle pour
imprimer une visière des premiers tandis
qu'il ya trois semaines donner des
tentes x à 4h à part l'impression
fabriquer un dispositif
il ya une espèce d'émulation de
compétition entre les différents goûts
différents modèles qui font qu'on est
descendu à remy 1h50 +48 et les derniers
modèles on arrive des choses
il
pour les pompiers pour les gendarmes
pour les infirmières pour pour le cis
pour les ehpad pour les aides soignants
[Musique]
c'est un progrès qui a débuté il ya pas
loin de trois semaines un peu plus de
trois semaines
et puis en fait tous à siliana femmes
puisque les infirmières libérales et
quand il a fallu qu'elle parte boulot à
trois semaines on s'est retrouvés un peu
paniqué en disant mais comment elle va
se protéger
[Musique]
et bien par le bouche à oreille les
soignants quels qu'ils soient qui
apprennent la démarche nous contactent
demande par mail et puis annonce des
bruits pourquoi des meters il avance
positionner et qu'ils vont dire ok mais
enfin dans quelques jours pour elle à un
tel intérêt
il ya des commerciaux dans le matériel
médical il ya des boulangers il ya des
gens qui bossent en lui disent les gens
qui passent en école de musique il y a
des preuves rio il ya plein de gens qui
[Musique]
je pense est cette chose là unique vient
de se passer
voici l'une des plus grandes
l'expérience industrielle des coûts par
la france depuis partout dans le monde
depuis depuis longtemps force des gens
qui se connaissent pas qui se met à
fabriquer un produit qui existe et pas
pour des gens qui ne connaissent pas
tout ça est libre et en temps et en
heure gratuitement naturellement
extraordinaire
[Musique]